[Musique]
la commune 19 est une maladie qui recèle
encore des mystères mais de là à croire
tout ce qui s'écrit sur ses causes et
ses conséquences
restons prudents près de vingt mille
c'est le nombre de partages de cette
publication sur les réseaux sociaux
il est affirmé dans les premières lignes
du texte en lettres majuscules
on s'était bien trompé sur le traitement
du corps est de 19
maintenant on sait enfin une déclaration
attribuée à jacques théron neuro
cardiologue du centre hospitalier
universitaire de caen en france
la soi-disant découverte évoqué dans ce
texte grâce aux autopsies pratiquées par
les italiens il aurait été démontré que
l'une des causes de décès des victimes
de la cave et 19 serait une thrombose
conclusion les respirateurs artificiels
et les unités de soins intensifs n'ont
jamais été nécessaires pour traiter la
maladie
il suffirait de prescrire au patient des
antibiotiques
les anti inflammatoires des
anticoagulants ou encore d aspirer le 10
août dans du jus de citron bouillie avec
du miel c'est tout premiers éléments
soulignés la personne à qui on attribue
ce texte ni l'avoir écrit joint par
courriel par mon collègue nicolas de
rosa jacques théron dit ne plus
travailler au chuq 1 depuis une décennie
maintenant parlons thrombose il s'agit
d'une maladie sanguine qui entraîne la
formation de caillots qui entravent les
vaisseaux sanguins médecins chercheurs
ont en effet constaté depuis le début de
la pandémie que la thrombose et est une
complication fréquente chez les
patientes kobe 19 mai la publication
virale va si loin en affirmant que
l'acte rambo est l'unique cause de décès
liés à la comédie 19 ans les résultats
d'une cinquantaine de toxines dans la
ville de bergame en italie en seraient
la preuve
or il n'existe aucun travail de
recherche italien avançant que l'unique
cause de décès des victimes de com et 19
et la thrombose plusieurs études en
europe révèle la présence de caillots de
sang chez des patients ayant été testé
positif à la coke et 19 mai généralement
ces études concluent tout de même que la
copie 19 est une maladie respiratoire et
que les patients montrait des signes
cliniques et radiologiques de l'aumônier
au moment de leur hospitalisation
quant aux anticoagulants il était déjà
utilisé auprès de la quasi totalité des
patients de n'importe quelle infection
sévère avant même que la copie de ce
propos
ce qui somme particulier avec les
patients infectés à l'accord du 19 et
qu'ils ont davantage de caillots
sanguins pour plus de détails sur cette
publication trompeuse je vous suggère
fortement la lecture du dossier signé
nicolas de rosa sur notre page web
et n'oubliez pas d'adhérer à notre
groupe facebook d'écouter l'émission
diffusée les samedis dimanches sur icr
dit salut
[Musique]